el panorama es desalentador en europa
con cifras récord de contagios y muertes
prácticamente todo el continente está en
rojo en el semáforo de contagios
bélgica es actualmente la nación del
continente con mayor número de casos por
cada 100.000 habitantes
italia también registró un récord de
contagios por 19 por lo que el gobierno
decretó nuevas restricciones para frenar
la propagación de coronavirus que han
enfrentado protestas en las calles de
varias ciudades
los hospitales en españa' se empezaron a
llenar ante un virus desbocado las
condiciones laborales para los
trabajadores de la salud siguen sin ser
óptimas por lo que muchos salieron a
protestar en las calles de la capital
porque madrid tenemos unas condiciones
laborales muy malas tenemos un alto
índice de temporalidad inestabilidad
laboral no tenemos derecho al descanso
semanal que la ley reconoce porque no
estamos constantemente teniendo que ir a
los juzgados a defender nuestros
derechos y en alemania la falta de
personal en los hospitales es uno de los
principales problemas en la atención de
los pacientes con coronavirus el re
confinamiento del continente se siente
de nuevo en las bolsas europeas que han
vuelto a cerrar con pérdidas